julien baer est avec nous ce soir merci
julien dray il y avait également un
avocat qu'on adore qui extrêmement
sérieux et qu'ils nous éclaire à chaque
fois c'est maître roland perez merci
rejouer avocat aux barreaux
ils apporteront des éclairages
extrêmement important sur toutes les
affaires et d'ailleurs je rappelle que
vous êtes avec jean marc morandini sur
la quotidienne de crime sur nrj 12
voilà et d'ailleurs vous reviendrez sur
cette affaire de malan julien
franchement merci d'être là parce que je
sais que ça doit pas être facile pour
toi mais en ce moment il n'est pas très
facile mais merci de m'avoir invité me
laisser cette parole mike bossy
c'est important pour nous on en avait
mais nous même parler de ça dans cette
émission un moment parce qu'on avait vu
la une des journaux people et on avait
parlé toi et c'est vrai que tu m'avais
dit on s'était au téléphone et tu
m'avais dit cyril ça n'a rien à voir
c'est pas du tout ce que j'ai fait je
suis vraiment je suis victime d'une
machination mais d'un truc que j'ai pas
du tout fait tu vas tout nous raconter
parce que la justice te reproche donc
d'être impliqué dans une affaire de
trafic de drogue
alors pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi on
va on a fait un petit récapitulatif et
tu va nous dire toi
julien quelle est ta version et voilà où
en est aujourd'hui et ce qui va se
passer
regarde ça marche si julien baer est
aujourd'hui au coeur d'un feuilleton
judiciaire c'est à cause d'une affaire
qui remonte à 2015 à cette époque le
jeune homme a alors déjà star de la
télé-réalité est accusé par la police
d'être au coeur d'un trafic de drogue
d'une portée internationale
il est arrêté par la brigade des
stupéfiants pour détention et
importation de drogue ainsi que pour
association de malfaiteurs la police
reprochent aux jeunes hommes d'avoir
servi de mule à des trafiquants en
transportant à leur compte des valises
remplies de drogue à l'aéroport de punta
cana en 2014
immédiatement le jeune homme nie les
faits et explique que si son nom est
évoqué dans ce dossier c'est uniquement
parce qu'il a fait une mauvaise
rencontre lors d'un anniversaire il
aurait fait la connaissance d'un des
sommes liées à ce trafic
j'ai juste traîner avec des personnes
avec qui il ne fallait pas traîner à un
certain moment ni de loin ni de près
j'ai touché à de la drogue
après plusieurs rebondissements
judiciaires et avoir prouvé par test
sanguin qu'il ne se droguait pas julien
baer a finalement été condamné par la
justice le 7 mai dernier
à deux ans de prison dont six mois avec
sursis ainsi qu'une amende de 20000
euros
voilà je lien alors déjà maître roland
perez qu'est ce que ça veut dire
association de malfaiteurs qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que risque on a vu qu'il
risquait deux ans il a été condamné à
deux ans de prison
quels sont les recours déjà qui va
pouvoir avoir julien alors association
de malfaiteurs d'abord c'est un c'est un
délit que l'on peut retrouver
effectivement dans différents trafics et
notamment des trafics de drogue
lorsqu'on pense qu'une personne a
participé avec d'autres
d'autres prévenus un trafic quelconque
en l'occurrence là un trafic de drogue
la peine qui a été prononcée quand même
une peine très lourde pour quelqu'un qui
n'a jamais été condamné pour quelqu'un
dont vous qui se présentait pour la
première fois avec des éléments qui
laissent penser qu'il peut peut-être y
avoir un doute dans la commission des
faits pour lesquels on le lac finalement
comparu il ya vous savez ce qu'on
appelle un d'éléments matériels dans une
infraction est ce qu il a porté des
valises nom est ce qu'il y avait est ce
qu'on l'a trouvé en possession de drogue
non et puis un élément intentionnel est
ce qu ils savaient ce qu'ils
connaissaient est ce que ces éléments là
normalement doivent conduire ou non à
une culpabilité est là a priori la
culpabilité pour ce seul délit puisque
il n'a pas été du tout était poursuivi
pour avoir pour avoir porté transporté à
importer de la drogue il a tout
simplement été poursuivi pour s'être
associé à de prétendus malfaiteurs
dans ce cas là la peine est extrêmement
lourde et je pense qu'il a il a
effectivement tout intérêt aujourd'hui à
faire appel de cette décision c'est
appel de la décision fait qu'il est
aujourd'hui présumé innocent ça très
important on le répète ici aujourd'hui
en direct à 22h59 junior est présumé
innocent puisqu'il a fait appel alors je
viens donc un chef d'inculpation a été
retenu contre vous comme vous l'avez dit
comme on l'a dit celui d'association de
malfaiteurs vous avez des mauvaises
rencontres
alors puisque dans les médias j'entends
parler de drogue de trafic de
stupéfiants de valises de cocaïne on va
on va s qui vous est reproché
julien pour nos téléspectateurs qui
connaît pas la faire alors alors j'ai un
chef d'inculpation qui est association
de malfaiteurs pourquoi donc c'était à
punta cana en 2015 caisse est en fait
j'ai rencontré des gens sur paris oui je
venais de ma petite banlieue de
saint-etienne pour moi tout était beau
tout était rose le monde de la nuit
donc on fait tout un tas de rencontres
en boîte de nuit comme n'importe qui tu
peux parler avec quelqu'un pendant des
heures et des heures et le revoir de
trois fois 100
réellement savoir ce qu'il fait dans la
vie donc on a cliqué sur cette personne
est partie en vacances je peux à punta
cana s'est voilà c'est ça on m'a proposé
un voyage à punta cana avec un pote à
moi tu fera de la pub de l'hôtel la base
sur place tu verras tu vas kiffer amuse
toi tu as tu as qui fait ça me fait
plaisir c'est une personne j'avais vu
aller une dizaine de fois ma boîte de
nuit tout le temps en boîte de nuit seul
vous saviez pas du tout kiss kiss qui
faisait nord on restait mon anniversaire
madiba tu sais quoi je te fait kiffer tu
pars une semaine à punta cana
bon je prends mon meilleur ami ou par là
bas et tout le séjour s'est très bien
passé même s'il y avait des trucs de
plus en plus louches plus les jours
avançaient en fait l'endroit retour
avancé
j'en rêvais sur place on a donné notre
passeport à un make way qui s'occupait
de nous organiser des activités mais ils
voulaient pas trop qu'on sort de l'hôtel
il voulait pas trop con à la boîte de
nuit je sais pas il y avait quelques
petits trucs un peu louche mais on est
quand même bon tu peux pas que tu peux
pas de doute et qu'il fait vingt deux
ans déjà c'était hier cinq ans était à 5
ans déjà il ya cinq arrivante dedans ça
voilà j'avais donc on retrouve la mine
de rien au coeur d'un magnifique
scandaleux stupéfiants de même que jean
ziegler de valises en fait
alors si l'histoire de valises c'est le
dernier jour cette personne nous a dit
vous n'allez pas montré que vos propres
valises vous allez rentrer avec d'autres
valises donc là on est en voiture on se
dirige vers l'aéroport parce qu'on sait
dire mais qu'est ce que tu me racontes
là non mais tu verras crois pas que tu
es parti si gratuitement tout à un prix
dans la vie donc là déjà on commence à
se regarder que le ton change dans la
voiture jusqu'à 15 assez nerveux et je
comprends qu'ils menacent en fait sur le
ton qui le dit menace donc j'écoute est
hors de question je ne ramènerai du tout
aucune valise
il ne m'a pas dit le mot mais j'ai très
bien compris ce qui allait avoir des
attaques contre la personnalité dans un
lalande a compris mon ami noël les pieds
et pour stopper tout ça j'ai dû en venir
aux mains là bas à punta cana avec ce
monsieur pour qu'il me rende mon
passeport mais qui nous avaient organisé
des activités toute la semaine donc
c'était très violent sur place j'ai dû
me battre pour récupérer mon passeport
et rentrer mes propres moyens avec mon
ami lui m'a menacé en disant france tu
vas tu verras ce qui va t'arriver
passage du salon alors c'est cette
personne qui vous a dénoncé je sais pas
comment ça s'est passé comment ça s'est
passé c'est parce que ils ont enquêté
sur toute cette affaire et qui sont une
trentaine de personnes au final quand
donc ils ont démantelé le réseau
c'est ça et j'ai apparus dont au sein de
cette affaire
non non vous êtes retrouvé dans un
traquenard plus de rien
et aujourd'hui 12 ans de prison avec
sursis comme on a dit avec comme mon ami
avec maître roland perret c'est énorme
vous avez fait appel donc tout est
suspendu pour l'instant mais j'ai envie
de faire appel mais julien droit
aujourd'hui mine de rien tout se passe
bien pour toi j'ai envie de pleurer
quand tu te prends ça dans la tête
ta famille je sais que tu étais italien
tu es d'origine italienne je sais que
quand je suis au téléphone tu m'as dis
moi ma grand mère tout mal et ça lui a
fait terriblement mal à cause des médias
on voulait la préserver de tout ça et le
journal de ma région
mamie en première page en mettant deux
ans de prison ferme c'est tout julien
baer deux ans de prison ferme
ma grand mère s'effondre il m'appelait
en larmes c'est un truc est ce que tu
dis à ta famille tu le raconte
l'histoire que tu es en train de nous
raconter
il connaît cela ils savent et c'est
vraiment la réalité de comment ça s'est
passé en plus fait a fait plus de cinq
ans et ça fait cinq ans qu'on vient que
ça on attendait ce procès pour pouvoir
tourner cette page là mais mais pensant
avoir une relaxe plaidé la relaxe s'est
pas passé comme ça alors je ne sais pas
pourquoi la juge n'est pas allé dans ce
sens là je sais pas comment bien faire
son métier ça se peut pas lui enlever
son job mais c'est pour ça que je fais
appel parce que moi j'aimerais que ce
soit au rheu juger cette affaire et
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait à peine parce
que je ne mérite pas cette sanction j'ai
été victime de ma naïveté ma crédulité
jeu et ça je ne sais pas ce que ça vaut
devant la justice mais pour moi j'ai été
victime de comment tu m'as dit que tu
vis aujourd'hui cette affaire et ce
jugement très mal ça fait quatre jours
que ça sort vraiment partout ça fait du
terriblement de mal à ma famille moi
j'ai les épaules solides ok je peux
encaisser certaines choses mais pas tout
non plus jusqu'à quand pourra encaisser
mais je me suis effondrée devant ma
grand mère si j'arrive à pleurer ça fait
des années que je n'ai pas pleuré à
cause de tout ça je me suis effondrée ça
m'a fait du bien mais je sais qu'il fait
terriblement mal à ma famille
indirectement mais les médias relèvent
volée par tous à rouler si je suis passé
j'étais là le petit clown le petit
charme airs de fille le petit tombeur de
défier en télé réalité à aux trafiquants
de re 6
juste d'entendre ce mot c'est terrible
d'être récusé tout ça jean michel bayet
mon témoignage certainement aucun point
mais j'ai eu l'occasion de voir souvent
en juillet les mêmes partis en vacances
une fois ensemble dans une espagne donc
j'ai vu pendant longtemps ou nuitées
jour etc
lors du ce et qu'on peut lui reprocher
de métro la fête des métros les filles
tout ce qu'on veut mais je n'ai jamais
vu faire une seule activité qui se
rapproche de trop de lois avec
l'illégalité c'est un gentil garçon
franchement de ce que j'ai vu je pense
pas qu'il ait changé comme ça et
franchement moi j'ai que du bien à dire
lui ça assez à ce jour cinq potes sympa
c'est un mec sympa j'ai jamais eu je le
vois pas du tout tomber dans ce genre de
trucs alors julien merci sur toi
aujourd'hui tu te retrouves au milieu de
tout ça c'est qu'il ya plein de jeunes
qui nous regardent mine de rien qui te
regarde tes l'idole de sacs jaunes john
est l'exemple de plein de jeunes qui te
regarde et pour eux tu as toujours eu
l'image du sportif du meg aulaqi qui
drague médecin toi qu'est ce que t'as
leur dire aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui se disent aujourd'hui
je te lis julien baer a oui mais
aujourd'hui j'ai pu le regarder j'ai pu
le suivre peut-être parce que il est
appliqué dans un strict contrôle
non mais je leur en veux pas je les
comprends tout à fait est ce que tu peux
comprendre mine de rien aussi c'est ce
qu'on dit ici aux lacs homme a été
condamné à deux ans de prison ferme
moi je te dis la vérité ce matin au
bureau j'étais beaucoup défendu et a les
mecs qui te connaissais pas que nous les
oem et s'il a été condamné et ben c'est
que mine de rien bah il est coupable
s'il était condamné c'est qu'il est
coupable mais oui mais alors là il ya ce
que ce que voilà ce qu'on a ce qu'on
peut penser comme ça de façon assez
commune 1 / b
mais il ya aussi la justice il n'y
aurait pas le degré d'appel la cour
d'appel elle existe les juges peuvent se
tromper
les juges peuvent apprécier différemment
un dossier on le voit tous les jours des
décisions de relaxe devant la cour
d'appel pour des dossiers qui ont sont
qui sont examinées avec exactement les
mêmes scènes et même pièce mais qui sont
regardés tout à fait différemment et je
pense que vous avez dit quelque chose de
très juste c'est à dire que le procureur
qui représente l'état lorsqu'elle fait
des réquisitions
elle prend elle prend la mesure de la
personnalité du prévenu et elle dit
c'est un exemple oui il est dans une
affaire de drogue c'est corrélé à cette
histoire de stupéfiants de drogue alors
qu'encore une fois il a ni consommer ni
parti ni transporté ni
ni a tenté quoi que ce soit pour autant
il est dans ce trafic de drogue et c'est
une image il a x millions de followers
sur c'est sur ces réseaux sociaux il
présente une image et on doit ça doit
être une vertu d'exemplarité et à partir
de là c'est la soeur damnation c'est que
ça a joué le fait qu'ils soient
oui oui oui bien sûr vraiment
l'exemplarité que représente ce jeune
homme sa réussite son ascension le fait
qu'il soit suivi comme ça par départ
départ des jeunes qui voient en lui
voilà une réussite une promotion sociale
forcément on s'est dit il ay las il a
participé il faut montrer que la loi
doit s'appliquer s'accorde plus à ce
type de personnalité et je pense que ça
a dû jouer
hélas en sa défaveur mais mais je pense
encore une fois que s'il ya un doute et
personne n'est là pour savoir ce qui
s'est réellement passé mais s'il ya un
doute dans le dossier et si la justice
n'a pas la preuve de la culpabilité
certaine il doit être relaxé
oui parce que la justice est au courant
que ce n'est ni de près ni de loin a
touché à la drogue et encore moins à en
ramener jeanne en effet certainement
d'affaires déteste d'ailleurs c'est un
voilà c'est un sanguin bray vous n'avez
gérer dialogue donc vous vous êtes
retrouvé vous nous avez raconté
l'histoire donc vous retrouver au milieu
donc cauchemar là et avec et les valises
ou les avait jamais touché jamais ma vie
jamais j'arrive n'ai même pas vu de
ville accorde les mêmes peuvent donc guy
mohamed mais alors ma position un peu
difficile parce que je veux pas du tout
être méchant je vous connais absolument
pas non mais c'est bien d'avoir un avis
de quelqu'un l'histoire j'entends jean
michel il est très sympa machin
effectivement vous avez très sympa mais
ça paie là vous n'êtes pas coupable je
suis désolé les témoignages annexes et
je veux pas dire se sait trés
habilitation contente de faire pour dire
que vous êtes quelqu'un de bien et très
certainement vous l'êtes moi ça marche
pas en revanche ce qui me perturbe c'est
quand on sait que la justice peut se
tromper et des innocents provence trouve
en prison mais j'aimerais comprendre
vous parlez d'exemplarité de la peine
mais exemplarité de la peine lorsqu'on
est coupable mais si on est innocent
pourquoi on devrait avoir une peine
exemplaire sous prétexte qu'on aurait
finalement une influence donc qu'est-ce
qu'on vous reproche concrètement pas ce
que vous dites moi ça reste un bon jeu
suit et les secteurs landa je me dis
c'est un peu vague vous avez pas
transporter ça vous dit j'ai été à plus
de takana j'étais en vacances mais le
juge quand même il est pas débile mais
deux en prison avec six mois de sursis
c'est quand même j'ose espérer qu'ils
avaient moins d'un doute et conventions
prison ferme avec sa fille alors julien
cours des choses
les passeurs de drogue parce qu'il y en
a qui ont été jugés
moi ces mécanos près la même peine que
moi c'est mon classeur n'est pas sûr de
drogue et massa comment parce qu'il vous
qu'on fouille alors c'est une franche et
parce qu'ils le savent que je n'ai pas
transporter de drogue c'est une réponse
d'abord tester la fiabilité des douanes
pour le biais d'une association de
malfaiteurs ces cas soient donc vous
êtes inculpés
enfin vous êtes condamné donc pour moi
reporter cette voie là pour un test
comme un testeur testeurs de à deux ans
de prison ferme et six mois avec sursis
et 20000 euros damende sans avoir touché
les valises ils vous ont dit guen a donc
ils ont cru à votre histoire de valider
nos bons après ils savent que j'ai rien
mais parce que tout le monde était sur
écoute tous ces gens là et la corderie
celui de régulation juste derrière à
mener mais pour eux c'est j'ai tester la
fiabilité de cette association de
malfaiteurs pour eux je fais des tests
aux douanes moi ma musique comprends pas
je il ya certains pourraient pas parce
que vous êtes un et pourquoi je prends
la même peine que des passeurs de drogue
je ne veux pas les enfoncer mais
pourquoi je prendrais en fait on aurait
pu on aurait dû lui rendre chez
éventuellement de non dénonciation d'un
crime c'est ça des lycées il savait à un
moment donné c'était déjà trop tard ils
étaient sur place c'est il n'est pas il
travaille pas pour la police il est pas
un dit qu'il ait pas délateur il n'est
pas à partir du moment où il était lui
même victime de d'après d'après les
éléments que vous nous livrez à partir
d'un moment il était lui-même victime de
ce que de ce qu'ils découvraient sur
place qu'est ce qu'il aurait dû faire il
est parti oui alors qu'il aurait dû pour
autant appeler la police est ce qu'il
aurait dû dire aux douanes attention il
ya une association de malfaiteurs france
et que ces milieux sont quand même
extrêmement dangereux si l'on crée
coupable à seulement un seul pour cent
je serais pas ici bien sûr que j'aime le
plus courageux devenait il n'a pas été
loin d'être innocent et c'est pour ça et
moi julien mais après il ya eu plein de
mecs qui sont passés en télé nous avons
été coupables jour terrienne plein d'à
priori oui il entache quand même là
aujourd'hui j'en ai eu plein de mecs
vraiment y arriver il est bas c'est pas
moi vous voyez que mails cahuzac aussi
les mains des cieux alors juste julien
pas son aplomb tu vas passer un message
juste après magali berda vous vous
occupez julien vos actions vous êtes son
manager ouais voilà qu'est ce qu'on
attend que vous avez à dire est ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi
parce que eric même julien il arrive
même pas de dire pourquoi il a été
condamné
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est victime
un petit peu de la violence de la
médiatisation je dirais c'est à dire
qu'en plus on est connu au plus on est
regardé aucune est jugée il s'est fait
lyncher là
sur les réseaux sociaux avant même que
la justice ne le lâche moi j'ai reçu des
appels de la presse avant même le procès
on lui a posé beaucoup de questions
c'est un lynchage quotidien que vivent
les candidats de télé réalité
ce qui est sûr c'est que je pense qu'il
faut relever un gros problème aussi ces
jeunes ils sont ils sont propulsés en
télévision ils ont pas l'entourage
peut-être nécessaire pour certains et je
pense qu'à des groupes se sont associés
à ce niveau là il s'est retrouvé hongrie
ni quand l affaire alors juste vous
étiez au courant de cette affaire de
punta cana où vous le connaissiez pas
encore oui moi je sais moi julien
toujours été transparent avec moi donc
et donc et vous vous n'avez pas senti le
truc que c'était bizarre venant de lui
moi je connais julien maintenant depuis
depuis trois quatre ans je sait
décrypter dans ses yeux sa sincérité
enfin j'espère du moins et je le crois
et je lui fais confiance et moi je suis
pas là pour le juger je suis pas la
justice moi je suis là pour
l'accompagner dans les eaux et les
mauvais moments
donc en aucun cas c'est mon rôle de le
juger et de le lyncher donc donc il a
été honnête avec moi il m'a dit la
vérité après j'ai accepté travail est
cuit en toute connaissance de cause
est ce que la justice doit demander
julien de témoigner contre ces personnes
non non non je ne sais pas si j'aurai
vraiment pris la liste de le faire parce
qu'à bien sûr vaille c'est ça dans ma
nature déjà vous avez au secours depuis
ses 5 ans ce que vous avez eu d'autres
contacts avec ces personnes qui étaient
ligue n'en a prouvé que ce réseau du
doigt coupé les ponts avec ces gens là
du tout ils ont droit essayer de vous
recontacter vous menacez nous n'en ont
pas du tout c'est ce qu'on m'avait dit
là-bas sur place en moins vous avez dit
pour mac avec la personne de mehdi tu
verras en france qui va t'arriver toutes
sortes de menaces gpal formulées ici
mais monsieur henri vraie menace
quatre avocats de la défense étaient
mauvaises peut-être je sais pas j'ai pas
envie de défendre à l'enfoncer moi ok je
pense qu'il a très bien fait son travail
après peut-être changé je sais pas
on veut bien discuter et crawl en fut
peut-être le futur si tu peux trouver du
travail ici
ce terreau non mais tu viens quand tu
veux oui valérie comment votre avocat a
justifié le fait justement que vous
preniez deux ans là puisque c'est son
métier dont pluie est capable de
décrypter les médinas comment est-ce que
lui vous a justifié le fait que vous
ayez lui-même ne comprend pas les mêmes
ne comprends pas cette décision et les
autres avocats présents dans la salle
je vais maintenant procureur avait
demandé j'ai dit parce qu'on répète même
pourquoi parce que donc j'ai pas j'ai
pas les faux bien il faut bien payer là
dessus j'ai pas les chefs d'inculpation
de trafiquants de drogue
j'ai juste association de malfaiteurs et
on a demandé sur quoi se basait pour me
mettre cette peine qui énorme peine
plancher même parce qu'à tester la
fiabilité des douanes pour le bien d'une
association de malfaiteurs alors julich
la fois que je t'avais demandé tout à
l'heure ce que tu as un message à faire
passer à ta famille aux jeunes qui te
regarde ce que tu as un truc à leur dire
ce soir
ben déjà je suis venu ici j'essaie de
leur montrer que je garde la tête haute
à ma famille parce que j'ai ils ont été
indirectement salies aussi de cette
affaire ils ont été énormément touchée
mais je pense que ma mère ma grand mère
ma soeur savent très bien qui suit ma
mère c'est très bien qu'elle a mis un an
et au monde n'est pas un diable est pas
un trafiquant est pas tout ça mais si
j'ai un message pour les jeunes c'est
redoubler de vigilance sur les
rencontres que vous allez faire
méfiez-vous vraiment surtout dans le
monde de la nuit moi j'arrivais de
saint-etienne tu arrives à paris pour
moi c'était le monde des bisounours
c'était avant que faisait des cadeaux
dans tous les sens tu passes en boîte on
t'offre une bouteille de champagne parce
que il t'a vu dans une télé tue la
chérir c'est tout un engrenage qui va
falloir faire attention et je mets en
garde tous les jeunes et